You're probably familiar
with enumerations and
structs from other languages.
Enumerations define a set
of related values, and
a struct is a convenient way
to bundle properties together.
In Swift, enumerations and structs are
more powerful than in other languages
because they can have their own methods
and are able to conform to protocols.
In other words, in Swift,
it's easy to give an enum or
a struct its own suite
of functionalities.
Let's start with enumerations.
Enums are usually used for
a finite set of values.
An enum of the primary
colors would look like this.
You start with the word enum,
followed by the name of the group, and
in between curly braces you have a list
of members preceded by the word case.
Here's another example.
This is an enum my aunties.
Notice that you don't have to write
the word case for every member.
You can use this shorthand in which
members are separated by commas.
You might be used to enums having
integer values like they do in C.
In Swift, enum members can take
on a value of any primitive type.
For example, I have this enum of
the American League West Division.
Let's say I wanted each member
to hold the value of their
home city as a string.
I just indicate string up here
next to the name of the enum,
and then I can define those values
in the enum definition like so.
You can access those
string values like this,
with the built-in property rawValue.
Enums and switch statements
work really well together.
Here's a statement that switches on
the value of the variable destination.
Destination is an enum
of type California park,
which you can see has four members.
This statement prints out
different warnings based on which
enum member matches
the value of destination.
Notice that if I leave out one of the
parks, the compiler gives me a warning.
This can be especially helpful
if I add a value to an enum
after I've already used
it in a switch statement.
The compiler helps me make sure all
my switch statements are exhaustive.
As you saw up here, initialization
of an enum type is really simple.
They're just defined with
a specific member of the enum.
Alternatively, they can also
be designed with raw values
like these city strings we used for
the American League West, or
they can be defined with what
are called failable initializers.
For more on those options, follow
the link in the Instructor's Notes.